good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy oh my god
it's only tuesday
hope everyone's having like a decent
tuesday as good as can be given the
circumstances given the circumstances
yeah per my last email
i'll follow up when it's friday and i
will be ooo extremely soon by etd i will
be ooo what's etd
eod sorry i've worked in an office in
like 10 years
happy tuesday welcome back to the
morning toast i have bryce in tow with
me because i need the spirit of bryce to
get me through i'm so tired my aura
sleep score is not good praise the lord
please the bryce plays the bryce i
thought
i thought maybe you didn't catch that
never
um today's a really exciting day because
it's magnolia's birthday oh yeah two
years old want to give a shout out to
knowles bruno is packing
he's things he's d are you okay tonight
he's so excited to take you to the
maldives for your requests they're gonna
have a great romantic getaway and
thrice will be there in spirit are you
done larping
we'll see yeah we'll see um it's tuesday
we've got a great show for you guys
mediocre stories um but high energy and
enthusiasm from two of your favorite
gals your favorite gals that's us also
your favorite gal spoke to your favorite
person yesterday frank catania came on
the toast the interview is already up on
our youtube
you better [ __ ] subscribe
especially because the interview was so
good so fun it's really a visual
experience you know it's sensory
overload best enjoyed on the telly but
if you are in a situation where you
can't turn on the telly and you're
listening as a podcast it's at the end
of the episode and you will thoroughly
enjoy just the preciousness let's talk
about the frank experience yes um frank
walked in 20 minutes early we stand a
respectful king we do
but i was pumping
but you know what he took it like a
champ and you know what i for some
reason like i didn't feel like it was
weird you know like he's a dad no i feel
like what like for someone who's had
kids
it doesn't faze you but if
it's someone who hasn't had kids it
would be so much weirder right like we
were saying like if austin kroll walked
in on you pumping i would have to
flee this country right yeah but no it
wasn't weird at all and he gave you like
such nice fatherly advice he's like
don't blink man don't blink oh my god he
gave such great advice he was being so
cute before the show we did a great like
30 minute interview nothing you know
actually there was some good tea spilled
um about jackie and about ultimate girls
trip so it's a juicy interview but it's
also just like
who is frank catania yeah get to know
frank on a deeper love and i feel like
once you reach that level he's the same
prank
yeah no and that's what like my major
take away from the from the show was
like he is the same guy on the show as
he was on this couch as he was when he
walked in on you pumping and that
that's really all you can expect from a
hero it's it's it's more than what you
can expect no i'm feeling encouraged to
meet more of my heroes
because it was a positive experience
yeah and did you ever know that you're
my hero
you know i've been watching re-watching
30 rock and like i
am jenna maroney to the point where like
i hate me too you know i love jenna
maroney that's why it works because like
she's my favorite character and she's
you it's so true who am i
she by the way she's not my favorite
character at all oh i love jenna what
does that say about me because like
selfies i see so much of myself in jenna
and she's probably my least favorite
character self-hating jenna what was
your question who am i
i think i'm jack donaghy
i think like you wish you were sure i
didn't really think about i think i'm a
combination honestly of jack donaghy and
kenneth the page i was gonna say you're
giving kenneth energy i give both
because like i
there's something very jack about me no
you're very authoritative but like
you're kenneth in the sense that like
you have a moral compass and you will
not let it no matter the entertainment
hollywood is calling no one
can take you away from your moral
compass
i would hope so that's what strives to
be thank you for seeing me in that way
and that's very kenneth
today at the end of the show spoiler
alert kenneth becomes like this chairman
mm-hmm
deservedly so deservedly so but he's
still that boy from georgia yeah and
you're still that gal from new york from
down the block totally
um
so that's your little 30 rock recap
that's hard to say 30 rock recap three
rock recap thirty rack we kept thirty
rack we kept thirty rock reaching be
happy
seem to be having the easy um we've got
a great show for you guys today anything
you want to catch up on has haroldson
doing besides just like breaking
barriers left right and center he's
actually doing really well for every
down there is a swing back up and he had
a really good night even though like i
couldn't get back to sleep which is so
frustrating i even had to break out my
kindle in the middle of the night to
lull me to bed yeah um because i'm
reading this book which is a good book
it's just a little slow it's about the
history of the plaza hotel and so it's
really just you know
a picture of new york from the gilded
age till today and it's interesting to
see the way that like the hotel changed
with the city during war time during
depression during times of great
abundance prohibition it's just slow but
you know it's the perfect thing to put
you to bed yeah because like sometimes
you're reading a book that's like really
juicy that's like the worst thing you
can do because you don't want them down
no yeah exactly this is not that but i
also think that the percentage is going
by really slowly because there's an
extensive bibliography at the end so i
think i'm going to get to like 70 of the
books over right that's happened to me
before i feel extremely triggered by the
word bibliography yeah and i mean it
better be chicago mla yeah whatever mlm
bibliography is an mla it better be
bibliography lularoe
yeah mla annotated yeah like that is so
unbelievably triggering to me like
just remember the days where like we had
to write so many essays and they had
like minimum page lengths and like we
were doing
everything in our power to make them
longer who remembers making all the
commas and the periods like three times
three spots bigger that was desperate
time yes desperado
the margins of course of course the
margins and then the bibliography like
making it really wordy just to like
contribute to the illusion that your
paper was long you know that your paper
was good yeah of course and by the way
there's so many like
tools out there for kids now like to
help with essay writing and like we had
none of that it was bootstrapping what
tools like there's literally a website
called like writemyessa.com
and like you can literally just start
typing random letters about you have to
put in the subject and you start typing
random letters and it generates an essay
for you you're lying i swear
that's crazy i mean i'm sure it's a
piece of [ __ ] like for me it was dark
days it was like yahoo answers like
i like i literally never forget i wrote
a whole paper on the um origins of
ethiopian jews and like literally my
entire paper was from yahoo answer like
for them did you citate them no you
can't citate a yahoo answer no you can't
but that's really
a life hackers block quotes as long as
you let them know where you found it but
see the thing is with the the origin of
the ethiopian jews it's actually quite a
mystery as to like um and you didn't
solve it no of course not so it's like
historians couldn't even solve it and
i'm in the eighth grade supposed to they
asked you to just no but like i don't
i don't know but like i just didn't feel
like i was up to the task okay and
clearly it's still haunting you maybe
you should seek a book on it maybe
finally get some answers no i do believe
that the origin story of ethiopian jews
is like incredibly fascinating yeah but
now i just associate it with my eighth
grade term paper
that's the thing about school
what subjects that might otherwise be
interesting to us we just like
automatically hate because it's in
school you know it depends it all
depends it depends on the teacher it
depends on your stage of your life it
depends what else you have going on
because like i'm so obsessed with the
history of new york it's so weird i'm
not obsessed with the present right just
the past of this town and i actually
took a class in college the history of
new york and i loved it yeah so like you
would think i've already learned all
these things but i literally will read
stuff that should be something that's
ingrained in me and it's like i'm
hearing it for the first time also i
watch ken burns's new york documentary
so many of the same themes obviously
yeah i guess i'm like on a different
level in the sense that like
i know an embarrassingly small amount of
history like
ask me something like about american
like any history like just ask me and i
swear to god like i don't know it okay
um
i'm gonna just who was
who signed the emancipation proclamation
abe lincoln i don't know genius girly
yeah but like you know
like beyond that
when did women get the right to vote
give me a
like you can give me a decade
i have literally no idea but i do know
that we were suffragettes right yep we
were
suffragettes uh ask me another one i
don't know if it's suffragettes like i
made it a little bit like a selfish
um
when
did the titanic sing i okay i only know
this because of downton abbey in 1912.
gorgeous until i watched downton abbey i
had no idea i thought it was like 1500s
i don't know okay how did world war one
start
now world war one is tricky it's really
convenient because it's not world war ii
and nobody knows anything about it i
don't know who the major players were i
do remember something about the allies
and submarines
okay um but what was the question who
was it between how did it start
as all wars start
cannons
sure cannons into the ocean
sure no let me guess let me guys okay no
if you don't know what you're not like
no no i know it how did world war one
start um
was it the price of gas
no
was it okay i'll give you a it was an
assassination of who oh wow
jeff twisted jfk
no i know that's like later an
assassination
of
who else was assassinated lincoln no
that's really early it's someone not
someone here oh how the [ __ ] am i
supposed to because it's just like i
don't know i feel like it's seared into
everyone's brains archduke franz
ferdinand oh yeah sorry i forgot it was
seared in my brain the archduke
ferdinand fran
friends
the archduke franz ferdinand okay but
also like it's so crazy history is so
extensive but i'm so focused on like 200
years but like you know
cleopatra helen of troy yeah i feel like
where i um we're using these pillows
like therapy bills
for dear life it's like a stress pillow
someone's like watching this show they
think we're like unwelcome well these
are literally the best pillows the best
things that ever happened to us it's so
crazy how we can get a gift that
is so thoughtful that it's really the
best gift i've ever gotten this my ray
done mug like i'm just on a thoughtful
gift trip and honestly a pillow like
this like you know when you have your
period and you're having cramps and you
just like have to put a pillow up
against your belly yeah do you know that
feeling yeah that's where i'm at right
it's only these were heated
that's next if you could like put like a
microwave pad in it's like a fire hazard
waiting to happen yeah okay back to your
history lesson yes look i really know
nothing i had one more question i was
gonna ask you but i um i feel like you
know american history like 13 colonies
like that stuff i kind of know but
everything else 72 76 okay so where did
the pilgrims land plymouth rock gorgeous
yeah that's actually not my specialty
that's also like not for me like the
pilgrims like to me i don't think of
that as history i think of it as like
literally like fable because the way you
learned it is like yeah yeah so what
were the three boats
the nina the pinta and the santa maria
yeah yeah and
1492. don't [ __ ] with me oh i wasn't
yeah i don't go back that like i don't
that doesn't interest me when i'm
reading historical fiction i'm not
reading 1400 do you ever learn like an
interesting fact like a trivia fact and
you just wait for that fact to like
become pertinent and be like how did you
know that yes i just had one and like i
just learned something and i keep
waiting for someone to bring it up like
it's never going to be why are you
bringing it up
chicken let me ask you a question sure
in your you know opinion
what state do you think has more miles
of coast california or maine
well obviously you would think
california so the answer is maine yes
because california it's like just the
coast so it goes all the way down the
coast but maine has all these little
inlets so it's like re right
yeah that's my interesting fact of the
world so i think you could find a way to
work that in too it's never going to
come up naturally but yeah how about
this
state with the most coastal
i don't know mileage i feel like it
would be then if it's more than
california so you could say oh i'm
thinking of moving i i love the coast
i'm tempted to move to maine did you
know that it has the most coastal
mileage of any state yeah or when i find
myself like talking about plymouth rock
you know from the boats i could be like
if only they landed in maine the state
with the most coastal mileage
that's good that's really good yeah it's
seamless
um so yeah that's your history lesson of
the day
and what was i talking about oh i guess
the book is the book you couldn't fall
asleep last night we went on a major
tangent majored him all to say that
harry's doing well yes very well so uh i
guess without further ado yeah it's like
a tuesday it's a boring tuesday it's
gloomy outside it's quiet
so i don't know it's kind of good vibe
though it's a good vibe it's a good vibe
for sure yeah i like a quiet tuesday i i
like a quiet tuesday but i prefer a
quiet tuesday where i don't have my
period you know if i had to like put
together the perfect tuesday yeah so you
have your period yeah i brought it up
twice now so i thought maybe wait i
didn't hear it the first time no i said
remember when you you know when you put
a whatever yeah okay i'm sorry i'm a
very idiot i'm sorry
so that's exciting have you gotten your
period yet no i have not i thought i was
about to because i was experiencing like
pain
but i don't think so i think it was a
false alarm just hunger
perhaps perhaps perhaps um okay well
that's the fertility news of the drive
and now without further ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
now it should come as a surprise to
nobody that i'm not a fluent speaker in
many languages
comes to mind um but i'm going to italy
this summer and i do need to like you
know figure my [ __ ] out and that's why
babel is here for us for all of your
summer travels whether you're going
abroad staying domestic or you want to
immerse yourself in the culture now is
the perfect time to start babble babble
is the language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to babble's addictively fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination it is
the perfect thing to do before a trip it
is so easy it's kind of intimidating to
learn a new language but when you're
traveling or whatever your reasons are
but especially when you're traveling
like it's really um smart to have just
like a base knowledge of the language
just because it can be kind of you know
dangerous if you don't um you can get
lost you never know so babel is here for
you they make it super fun super easy
they've got little podcasts they've got
games you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real-life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
there are many ways to learn with babble
in addition to the lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel and right now you can save up to
60 off your subscription when you go
to babel b-a-b-b-e-l dot com tmt
that's babel.com tmt for up to 60 off
your subscription that's six zero you
guys that's a big discount babble.com
tmt babble language for life
today's episode is also brought to you
by thuma thuma practices an intentional
less is more design philosophy for the
bedroom with clean lines subtle curves
and lifestyle enhancing details thuma
proves that simplicity is the truest
form of sophistication introducing the
bed by thuma hand crafted from
eco-friendly high quality upcycled wood
you'll find beautiful unique variations
in the natural grain the minimalist
design featuring japanese joinery helps
elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress breathable and made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space so if your home
it's like your bedroom specifically is
really important to you which if you
listen to the show i just like feel like
it is yeah um creating my balance is
super
delicate and zuma helps you do that
their bed is just it's perfection and
now they offer other things they have
the nightstand but the bed specifically
is an amazing bed and it's also really
gorgeous and helps just like balance out
the vibes in your room you want a
balanced room you know
it's made for how you live the bed by
zuma is backed with a lifetime warranty
it ships right to your door and three
easy to maneuver boxes and it takes
about five minutes to assemble with no
tools required along with the bed they
offer other bedroom essentials to
elevate bedtime like the nightstand the
side table and the tray and they are all
perfect complements to the bed they also
work with one tree planted at thuma to
plant one tree for every bed and
nightstand sold
all of their essentials are green guard
gold certified create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel hotel suite at home
with thuma the bed by fuma and now go to
thuma dot co toast to receive a 25
credit towards your purchase of the bed
plus free shipping in the continental us
go to t h u m a dot c o
slash toast that's
thuma t h u m a dot c o slash toast for
25 credit
great thank you so much it's a pleasure
our first story halsey claims her record
label wants a fake viral moment before
releasing a song halsey claims their
record label capital music group won't
release their new music until they
create a fake viral moment
halsey has given their label a real
viral moment instead by calling out
executives on tick tock over the weekend
saying cool basically i have a song that
i love and i want to release asap but my
record label won't let me i've been in
this industry for eight years and i've
sold over 165 million records and my
record company is saying i can't release
the song unless they can fake a viral
moment on tick tock they said everything
is marketing basically it's being done
to every artist these days i just want
to release the music man and i deserve
better tbh i'm tired and tbh i hear
halsey but halsey is also um in turn
creating a viral moment for the song
right not a fake one i think probably
she realized that when she did this they
would get the viral moment that they
wanted now everyone's like what's the
song what's the song right but do you
think that this was like an intentional
i think it's a little bit of both i
think it's frustration but it's also a
way for her to kill two birds with one
stone and get exactly what
she wanted which is to release the song
and the record label got their moment
but it also is exposing the record label
for the record
label
um halsey's pronouns are she and they so
just moving forward um
i feel like this is like a trend with a
lot of artists on tick tock like either
they try hard to make a tick-tock viral
moment or they like go on and um
lament about the fact that they can't
release until they have a viral
tick-tock moment so to me this is just
like the culmination combination of both
of those like
part of you wants to like sympathize
with um
halsey but then part of you is like but
you're also
doing the thing that they want you to do
you know yeah but it must be really
frustrating and i mean
tick tock is so influential in music
right now so i understand
the urge but you can't fake viral you
can't make something go right viral and
why can't we still also just get music
on new music friday like why can't we
have both no and also i think that
certain people are at a point in their
career and i would include halsey in
that category who don't have to do dumb
things like this
if you are up and coming and like the
marketing around like the perfect
example is um tate mcrae
she's like so tick-tock-y like every
time so funny i was just listening to
her on spotify yesterday and every time
she has a new song she does the video on
it releases like a clip of the lyrics
people love it it becomes a moment and
then she releases it it's like the
perfect formula and for her it works and
for someone of that level in their
career like that's the stuff you need to
do i do feel like halsey is like a bit
beyond that at this point like she
really is like
a pop queen legend and like for her to
still be playing these like silly games
is dumb and that kind of just i just
feel like means she like works with a
record label who like doesn't really get
her yeah and she should be respected at
this point like she's earned her stripes
enough to know what her fans want yeah
and what's gonna hit
what is a hit in general like i think
when people complain about this and
they're not at this level like that's
the game now there's always been a game
in music and now it's tick tock yeah it
might not be in another year but that's
the game so you want to get in the music
industry you have to play the game but
for halsey it's like really like taylor
swift isn't doing this you know yeah she
does other stuff though yeah everyone
has their own thing and halsey knows
like her brand and what would work well
and what has worked well in the past i
think like but actually this is her
brand being
open maverick
and exposing yeah the industry but see
halsey has been on the receiving end of
viral um
campaigns on tick tock and it was
totally natural people were using her
song
just made you mad
and i had no warning to share their own
stories about like being in abusive
relationships and that did make the song
go viral and these things happen
naturally so to like try and manufacture
it is like not it it's so tacky yeah and
i would love to maybe you know of
instances that were manufactured that
you can tell that worked
no that's a thing like the sheer
nature of it being manufactured means it
can't go viral viral is like so natural
the craziest do you know what's going
viral right now i don't even know it's
from real housewives of atlanta no one
knows it's candy burris legs and hips
and body body i think it's like from an
episode where they like recorded a song
or something it's so random that's the
thing it's like you can have the biggest
song ever it's like it's not about that
it's like niche audios most like major
major audios on tick tock you couldn't
find the origin right if you wanted to
uh wake up in the morning like we know
the arts we do but others don't like
right it's so random and so to try and
make it happen is so lame and that's why
i think like
charlie puth like the way he goes about
doing it people like really don't like
because it's so obvious
he's like on tick tock and he has a
decent following he's like what if i
made a song out of this
and then he'll show you the process of
making any turn and then it's a song
called light switch you know like he
started the tick tock what if i made a
song out of this and then he flicked on
the light switch
you turned me on like a light switch and
for me that was like so manufactured
right and it didn't living run free it
didn't as is he in your mind yes it did
work in a sense but i don't think it was
nearly as successful as like those
really kind of grass roots
for natural viral moments but i do think
an artist like
charlie booth
needs to resort to some high drinks like
that exactly and he's also like really
perfect for because he is on an
on-the-fly musical creator he's doing
what he should be doing no i need not
agreed now wasn't you who said someone
said this to me like a couple months ago
when i like started my charlie puth like
hate train and somebody
made the perfect point and i don't know
if it was you but it probably was
because who else do i talk to
um they said
shawn mendes became everything charlie
puth was supposed to become not me i
felt like that was such a good analogy
because when you think of charlie putin
he was a snatcher the beginning of his
career like the first couple songs it's
been a long
name
now jew man friend and like he was
really becoming like this thing and he
was like so cute and everyone like loved
him and then like that's what shawn
mendes did like bigger and better and
like i literally forgot about charlie
pooth until he like started popping up
on my tic toc yeah
just like an interesting factoid
thank you i wonder if he was the one who
said that i think it was probably snitch
you talking it was a good call yeah i
just don't think about either of them
honestly so oh i do like this is like
why i couldn't sleep last night because
charlie truth was running through your
mind no and i was like what did charlie
do like that ruined all the momentum he
had we see that a lot in like people's
careers like they're having so much
momentum like them like you know that
they're gonna be the next big thing and
then it just kind of derails yeah i
would say probably poor management may
be a disconnect between their management
and themselves them wanting to do one
thing management wanting to another and
then they're just not going anywhere
yeah that's like always sad when it
happens yeah or maybe they're being
suppressed but these days if you love
someone you can have access to them yes
so that's pretty cool yeah
it's pretty cool to have access to the
artists that you love oh
i can hear them playing this on z100
yeah you know
who can make
music that you love hey
let's just oh that's something i wrote
thank you are you ready to send that to
charlie
we should collab 100 are you ready for
our next story speaking of a collab
kim kardashian is featured in a new
campaign by beyond meat as the company's
first chief taste consultant this
morning kim and beyond me dropped a
video showcasing kim as their new cto
chief taste consultant
she announced that she will be featured
in their new campaign as she is an icon
synonymous can win
i today's not my day so if you do it
again no it's you but you're doing i
don't have no listen you just create
it's a campaign a campaign with kim i
love you yeah it was intentional i just
not today okay i'm sorry i apologize no
no i don't need an apology it's just
it's going to keep happening i'm so
sorry it's going to keep happening it's
not like no it's going to keep happening
for you and for me
like i'm going to because i can't speak
today i know
kim will be featured in the campaign as
an icon synonymous with impeccable taste
in food fashion beauty and more she will
highlight the brand's delicious
nutritious and sustainable product
portfolio portfolio with their signature
recipes and engaging creative content
um i love this by the way first of all
kim is like notoriously plant-based
queen yes so it's definitely like a good
um they align the two brands they are
aligned um i have to assume like kim
just doesn't you know do any sort of
sponsorship i'm sure she like got a
chunk of like percentage in this company
or just a really big paycheck yeah no
but it doesn't seem like it's going to
be a one-time thing because she's like
the now the new chief taste officer so
like she's like she has a job and beyond
me she's going into the office and by
the way you know who else just did that
um you know carter's the baby company
they did it with hillary duff cute i was
in like the back of a taxi and it was on
like the abc seven what's her title like
chief cmo chief mom officer that's
really cute it was cute
other companies need a cmo i'm available
um i can work part-time whatever you
guys need i'm also available for a cmo a
chief um munchies officer so if you need
snacks um i can tell you which good ones
to get i won't go out and get them but i
could tell you which one you could be a
cao a chief anti-officer i could be a
chief anti-officer i could also be a cfo
chief fund officer oh that's good yeah
that's really good okay cpo chief party
officer we're available for hire this
seems to be like what brands are doing
i'm here for it yeah and my rate is
extremely reasonable it's just twenty
seven thousand dollars a minute um do
you think they get paid
a salary who
these new officers no i think like this
trend of celebrities becoming like
employees at companies is them like
doing a deeper long-term partnership as
opposed to just like being a
spokesperson and i do believe they take
stock in the company okay yeah i'm sure
perhaps kim did this beyond meat is
public
uh but i'm sure she also got paid also
the food that she was tasting in the
video good
looked so good i mean for me it would be
so good but do you feel like she could
influence even you to try beyond meat
chicken nuggets okay by the way i've had
a beyond burger at burger king i've had
it like at a restaurant they had to be
on burger um i've had beyond a couple
times i just don't see myself choosing
beyond over like gorgeous kosher ground
beef you know when there's
rarely kosher available yeah so when
they're when it's not available i
haven't eaten it before have you had
in imitation chicken fingers
i don't think so i have i've actually
been making them a lot at home gardein
has a uh a delicious frozen chicken
finger if gardein's looking for a cto
the thing is i'm too close to the
chicken fingers like i'm
i'm too familiar with the taste
the texture
the crunch but don't you ever have
chicken that just hits you sideways yeah
sometimes there's nothing weird i always
feel like bella swan in that scene when
she has the chicken and when she's
totally you ever have a bad piece of
chicken i'm like
you know i mean i've had a bad piece of
chicken in my life and it's literally
like a life-ruining moment for sure
um like but usually when i make them
myself like when i pop them in the
airfryer like from the freezer section
i can never get it right
literally they'll be black on the
outside raw on the inside i can't figure
it out i'm just following the
instructions on the box why don't you
use your oven does your oven not work no
it does but i have an air fryer so oh
that's pretty cool
do you have one i have one but it's not
set up it's in storage because i don't
have the countertop space for it your
kitchen i saw on well i also have like
an espresso machine i have other things
that you don't know if you do like if
you wanted an air fryer you would make
space for it mm-hmm i would but it would
look it would be horrible i have a
toaster oven you got the baby i have a
microwave that's my kitchen didn't come
with a microwave so it's on the counter
that's like twisty yeah it's really
weird but i have a chance i have a cool
microwave though so i've made it work
but like you live in like a really nice
apartment and there's like no
microphones and it's in the whole
building that's because it's so weird
units are the same
that's just like
why are we not
maybe maybe they're taking a stand no
you know who they developed you know who
i heard the developer was oh the mom the
mom from confessions of teenage drama
queen because she didn't believe in
microwaves okay but i saw something on
emily did an otto's story the other day
where her husband told her
that an air fryer is just the same thing
as using the convection setting on your
oven
see it just doesn't feel the same
because i cook on convection that's how
i cook i just feel like emily's husband
kyle is just trying to stop me from
living my best life yeah but kyle is
businessman beau i know so like we're
forced to listen to everything those
things know for sure and by the way it's
definitely made me look at my oven more
flatteringly like oh you're an air fryer
yeah i mean and i guess if you were to
like just like really boil it down like
an air fryer is just like a small oven
it's a small convection oven right i
think that's what he said
i'll have to look into it but um i will
not be getting rid of my air fryer i
don't think you should even though i
literally never never made anything
but you know what i do do
um
if i have like
mozzarella sticks like from the diner
that like
they took them out of the like they took
them out of the fryer too soon i'm like
like they're they're still kind of like
brown instead of
golden
i'll pop them straight from the tin foil
diner casing straight into the air fryer
don't put the tin foil in there oh yeah
no way or if they you had them you got
them a few hours ago you didn't finish
them you can pop them back in works for
chicken tenders too yeah but something
funny something funny about you is that
like when you cook
nothing comes out good no i've never
successfully
made something correctly
never in my life like you'll be like i'm
making panel vodka from scratch and i'm
drunk no and it's like you'll show me a
picture of it it looks amazing and
perfect like nothing you've ever made
has tasted right no the penny olive
vodka was literally so vodka-y i almost
vomited on the plate um i made over the
pandemic i tried a bunch so plain pasta
with like butter or sauce like that
doesn't count didn't you make chili
recently and it was sickly um
i wouldn't say sickly i would say
different you know unique yeah
but to your credit it must be hard
comparing what you're making to what ben
makes no also i really don't need to
cook like i literally live with a chef
right right but then also everything
you're going to make is going to pill in
comparison to the chef yeah but like i'm
like if i had to cook dinner and by the
way when i have children like i will i
can be ordering it every night right
like i have to cook i know how to make
like four things
the four things are schnitzel and i have
a very good recipe but like i would say
one in every four pieces is raw
i can make um taco
taco like white people tacos you know
you do love tacos i do but like
you know i wouldn't eat the big chunks
of meat because they're probably rare
um i can also make bolognese i can make
a bolognese sauce but the sauce um does
have mold in it
and the fourth thing that i can make is
um
grilled cheese is it just three
yeah i guess chili
i really can't make chili ben can it's
those are the three things rice
i can make rice minute rice specifically
actually nobody makes better rice than
me
except sometimes if i that's supposed to
be true because you're a rice
connoisseur and like you you love your
own rice i do but
so like i make it um in like basically
in a big tupperware i put like a cup of
rice and then a cup of water and
sometimes if i use um like a tupperware
that's not like
percent clean
the rice does have this like dirty dish
smell
so that's why i order in multiple times
a day why don't you ever make the bags
of rice it's not the same oh i've
started making those they're pretty good
no it's not the same it's crazy how you
can make a bag of rice in 90 seconds or
you can make rice on the stove and it's
45 minutes and one broken pan later
because you're not getting that [ __ ] off
the bottom no and i did that last week i
mean i was like i want like fresh rice
no sodium whatever and
one in every 10 grains was still
plasticky but do you know what like i
actually tic toc has really made me want
but i don't have the counter counter
space cooker yeah you need one i know
and like i love that little paddle you
need one more than you need an air fryer
i know because basically every meal i
have i'll have grilled chicken and rice
i don't really have meals without rice i
have meatballs and some rice yeah some
pasta rice is like water for you i
[ __ ] love rice juliana i eat a lot of
rice i need a i need a rice maker but
then also
okay i know what i'm getting for your
birthday no but the thing is i'm still
the one who has to put the rice in the
rice maker and it will be bad like it's
just it's not it's not something i can
do okay
okay
are you ready for our next story which
is some more food news we actually have
a lot of food news today
kanye has announced that he's
redesigning mcdonald's food packaging
with a visual of a reimagined burger
wrapper so he took to instagram to post
this new burger wrapper that really
looks like the future it's like a square
i don't know what it's made out of but
he's posted it to instagram and he said
that's next week it's fries i guess he's
redesigning their packaging too yeah
what do you think
um
i don't really know like
as a mcdonald's connoisseur i just feel
like that's you i'm definitely deeply
affected by this i also think that like
there was nothing wrong with the initial
packaging if anything it's i think it's
nostalgic for a lot of people like
there's a lot of love associated with
those old rappers so i i just don't i
don't really believe in fixing things
that aren't broken you know yeah but i
do love like a unique partnership slash
concept for kanye to express his
creativity and as long as he's not like
yelling at kim and pete like i'm happy
yeah and he's not like changing
recipes that you love also
even though this is a new futuristic
design it's still pretty classic for
mcdonald's so i think i love an update
of rebrand i mean i guess this is just
an excuse to go get mcdonald's which i
didn't really need but now that i have
one lunchtime speaking of new packaging
the spritz variety pack is now available
yes spritzsociety.com you can get all
the flavors in one box you don't if you
want to try them this is two of each
three cans two of each it's so great
love that synergy that was beautiful
yeah and it was designed by kanye mm-hmm
allegedly
um
so yeah i just like i'm trying to find a
[ __ ] to give and it's hard because um
i don't
but like cool you know yeah cool
whatever like whatever synergy brand i
didn't think that like the burger box
was that like the new one was like that
cool but how cool is it going to be it's
a burger box and they turn out millions
a day like and then they go in the trash
and it was never a problem to begin with
yeah but they like wrap it up and just
didn't have a lot of money and they put
it in a box no but they wrap it first
and without a lot of love i would say
i've never experienced that okay but so
it's kanye's partnership ensuring that
every worker has love in their heart
this looks like love
honestly it looks like kind of gross
well you wouldn't want it anyway no
but um i just think like what now that
kanye has his foot in the door at
mcdonald's he could you know make some
real changes to things that actually
need to be fixed like the ice cream
machines yeah
are you ready for an extra moving some
things around because it's some more
food news and i just want to
get out all this food new so that you
guys can sleep easy tonight
[Laughter]
knowing all of the other
food world is it the food news that's
brought to you by fastgrowingtrees.com
yes it is spring and summer are the
seasons for finally getting outdoors for
entertaining pool parties and barbecues
but if your yard looks like a plant
cemetery then you're not going to enjoy
it as much get your place looking like a
resort easy with fast growing trees when
it comes to caring for your plants know
how matters and that's why
fastgrowingtrees.com's
experts curate thousands of plant
varieties that will thrive in your
specific climate location and needs
there's no waiting in lines no messy
cars from hauling plants all over town
your order online or or over the phone
and your plants are shipped to your door
within one to two days plus their
growing and care advice is available 24
7. whether you're looking for increased
privacy shade add some natural beauty to
your yard
fast growing trees has the perfect
plants
and the expertise to help you find them
even if you never had a green thumb
they'll make you feel like you do a
million home gardeners have already seen
what fastgrowingtrees.com can do for
them so we are two girls who don't have
a green thumb i would say we have more
of like a
purple thumb um and fastgrowingtrees.com
is the perfect resource for people like
us because taking care of a plant can be
a lot of work but as long as you have
like a resource who can tell you exactly
what to do and they're suggesting plants
that are good for where you live the
climate it's really nice go to
fastgrowingtrees.com
toast right now and you'll get 15 off
your entire order get 15 off at
fastgrowingtrees.com
toast
we only do our plant shopping at
fastgrowingtrees.com and you should too
fastgrowingtrees.com toast okay our next
store i am a little nervous um to share
because you hyped it up no i just i
think you're going to be searching high
and low oh for a [ __ ] to give i don't
but i also think you might
whatever
edible burrito tape for mess free eats
has been invented by johns hopkins
students
a group of engineering students at john
hopkins university unveiled a
groundbreaking and mouth-watering
invention called tasty tape an edible
adhesive to keep all your favorite
ingredients tucked inside burritos and
wraps so it's an edible piece of tape to
keep your burrito together because these
enterprising students were just so
discouraged that their burritos were
constantly falling apart they spent the
school year perfecting the edible
adhesive strips as part of their senior
design project
she one of the students was eating her
burrito one day and it was just
everywhere and she was like you know
what this is a problem to be fixed tasty
tape is made up of an edible adhesive
comprising a food-grade fibrous scaffold
and some other stuff that's edible that
keeps the burrito together it was
unveiled weeks ago as part of the
whiting school of engineering's design
day
did you see that the group of femme
females i just want you to know it was
so serious it was made by female
chemical and bio molecular engineering
look dude oh sorry never mind i thought
it was a [ __ ] that i gave but it wasn't
no but this is really why it's so
important to go to college yeah right
that's what i was gonna say get a degree
in engineering i could just see these um
like students parents rolling their eyes
like 20 grand a semester to make up a
dumb ass invention no i actually think
this is like a decent invention no i
don't no i think that plenty of people
would like people love burritos they
fall apart they should go on shark tank
but see the thing is
here's the thing
a good burrito doesn't fall apart oh
so you're gonna be tasty but you just
didn't have the engine when they don't
like wrap it tight enough in the tin
foil like
that is poor burrito making what about
at-home burritos it is hard burritos in
my opinion shouldn't be made at home
it's really like maybe now they can be
with tasty tape this is so dumb like
beyond but i think people are like i
actually think man even like i'm sure
chipotle could license it other places
too like they really could have big
business on their hands i know but like
who wants to eat an adhesive even if
it's edible i mean it probably doesn't
taste like anything maybe it's made of
bean i know what if it's made of rice
she'll be there but you also don't love
burritos so this isn't a story you know
i don't love burritos but
i do eat a lot of like burrito-shaped
like wraps you know yeah you had a wrap
that was falling apart at the seams
for lunch over the weekend because that
was a poorly made wrap but i get that
wrap at that place for lunch literally
like multiple times a week and it's
usually wrapped to perfection i don't
have one complaint yeah so again it's
like we're creating it's like you know
what it is it's like the straws
it's like the problem with plastic
straws explain
we're creating a solution
but we're not fixing the problem wow i'm
literally on a roll ready i'm listening
like people ban plastic straws
because they were ending up in the ocean
sure but why don't we ban how they're
ending up in the ocean which is people
throwing them in you know
so it's like we're not actually getting
to the root of the problem we're just
creating a solution that doesn't
actually fix the initial problem same
with this adhesive tape the problem and
the people who are making bad wraps the
problem is the poorly made burritos and
wraps but we're creating an adhesive oh
let's just keep making bad burritos and
eat like chemicals at like this is so
dumb
sorry
it seems like you do give a [ __ ] yeah
actually i tricked myself into giving
one
i agree i don't totally see how it's
congress with the straws you try my
analogy uh i do i do but i also feel
like okay so
sometimes there are a lot of like tools
that are helpful for things that people
can't do properly at home you know but
like see the thing is with plastic
straws it's not like people are just
throwing plastics that's the issue with
the plastic shards it's like there's so
much plastic there's so much waste and
like the straws don't even make up one
percent of it right so like and we're
now throwing all this [ __ ] in the ocean
including plastic straws so you think
the way to solve that is just to get rid
of plastic straws
moronic and then uh have you seen the
masks in the ocean have you seen the
turtles wearing masks i know so like the
problem is obviously why is this trash
ending up in the ocean let's tackle that
instead of banning plastic surgery we
could maybe reduce plastic use across
all categories not just target one yeah
like the target one and you know what
the banning plastic straws it's a little
ableist 100
100 percent it's a little
ageist the elderly 100 percent babies
hundred percent rely on straws hundred
percent about yourself
don't get me started on the straws no me
neither because like when they first
started banning straws they were like oh
cause they're killing turtles in the
ocean i was like oh my that's terrible
yeah let's ban plastic straws and then
like one day it occurred to me i was
like wait
how are the straws getting in the ocean
and it's like human error yeah
so that's the problem not the fact that
plastic straws exist no and it's not
like only the straws are slipping
through right and ending up there's just
like that one picture of a turtle with a
straw shoved up those right yeah but
like there's still other terrible things
happening with other plastics oh the
things that keep beer cans together oh
yeah those are bad those are bad and
like beyond unnecessary yeah and you
know who doesn't use those spritz put it
in a box [ __ ] put it in a box it
doesn't use those put it about showing
you some put it in a box
spreadsociety.com code toast yeah
so like i just think like while
a lot of these movements like people
start with good intentions
they're placating
they're i don't really know what that
means but it felt like the right time to
use the word anyways
i don't know how to feel about this
story because on the one hand sure
decent invention on the other hand johns
hopkins university engineers engineers
biomedical students no it's beyond um
biomolecular engineering unless this was
like
extracurricular you know it was part of
their like design project and but that's
just they only did as asked no these are
like the smartest it's not the student's
fault you want to design something like
design a cure for cancer you know it's
not the student's fault no it's not the
student's fault it's curriculum it's
these institutions it's the curriculum
it's institutions
you said it sits i said it are you ready
for our fifth and final story
yeah because uh some of our favorite
people are on the cover of british vogue
being the stunning bride and groom that
they are brooklyn beckham and nicola
peltz are on the cover of british vogue
recreating some wedding looks and
revealing that their wedding was
inspired by david bowie and iman well i
was gonna ask if you thought that the
cover was like a photo from like the
wedding photographer or if they got back
in their wedding luke's i think they
like got back into character and they
took a bunch of wedding
themed pictures which i don't mind it's
kind of weird that it came out after the
wedding as opposed to like because i
feel like once you're married like
you're irrelevant no like your dress is
in storage like you don't care yeah but
when you're a
fiance a blushing bride to be there's so
much buzz you know so
i would have liked to see this last
month and it would have made me like
realize how excited i was for their
wedding but it's still gorgeous and
honestly as far as
couples on the cover of a magazine it
doesn't get better no it's really it's
quite something it's it's ethereal it's
elegant it's beautiful it's really
striking yeah as are they and i have
come to like really be become obsessed
with them but like i'm even more
obsessed with the family dynamic like
you're more obsessed with the drama and
the shade and like the possible toxicity
we don't really know but like we're
pretty sure no it adds up that there's a
little bit of beef and in attention
because you want to know why it would be
too perfect without yeah it wouldn't be
fair yeah but we all saw the blinds from
the wedding and the speeches yeah and
the distance but i feel like that's just
like
sometimes like typical wedding behavior
because
planning a wedding is so toxic toxic and
by the wedding like it's hard to you
know put your differences aside and so
maybe they're all fine but it was just a
long and i'm sure a wedding like that it
was a long process yeah i'm just really
curious about the relationship between
victoria and nicola like to me that i
think is the most interesting i always
up until the wedding i really thought
that victoria loved her because she
liked to post her on her instagram even
before they were engaged but the the
whole last name thing threw me off yeah
and apparently there was like a speech
and nicola wasn't even in there for it
and they only talked about
the kid brooklyn
yikes it's interesting but they look
beautiful on the cover yes and hopefully
the families can put their differences
aside at christmas
yeah and it seems like brooklyn and
nicola are so happy and that's all that
matters yeah and like that their star is
like truly rising i feel like for a
while nicola was like really um like
just when i was watching her career
peripherally like she was doing the most
to like be the most and wasn't becoming
the most and now i feel like where she's
at a place in her life where like this
wedding and this courtship like put her
on the level that i think she was dying
to be on for a while she can just be
nicola right she doesn't have to
act or we love her for who she is right
because i don't think i've ever seen her
act
no but i think she's in and we did this
so we did this imdb journey already but
i do feel like she's getting buzzed for
something maybe it's just her wedding
probably
anyways congrats
great uh great cover it's a british
vogue snack so elegance yeah there's
something so and i didn't think of it
yeah there's something so
sickening about british vogue like yeah
they do a good job it's very
aristocratic you know yeah well it's
also the editor there edward mm-hmm yeah
yeah
it's just cooler it's very edgy but
that's because of him yeah yeah but also
because it's british like let's be real
but
it's also because of him but american
could be that way you know but it's like
as an american like i perceive like
british is like high society cool you
know like that's just me being a loser i
understand i understand
that's our show
you needed to know every single story
everything
every morsel every detail every crumb um
but if you're listening to this podcast
it's not over yet
encourage your loins for our sit-down
interview with frankie tanya if you want
to watch it it's already up on our
youtube channel we dropped it up early
yesterday so our subscribers get a
little you know a little taste a little
special vip treatment and if that could
be you if you just [ __ ] subscribed
yeah because the subscribers they didn't
have to wait till we announced it they
knew they got an email
that's exciting i think they got a
notification it depends what preferences
right right and that's something you can
set yourself maybe you don't want an
email maybe you do right that's what's
so great about youtube it's customizable
it's customizable and similar to your
life
yeah i said what i said
thank you so much
for listening to the morning dose the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday and
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast will be found so spotify itunes
central public radio i have radio cats
box all the places waivers and i'll find
out some morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are have an amazing tuesday and
you know what that means the next time
we see you it'll be
happy birthday magnolia we love you guys
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow bye
you